lo hacemos para cambiar de tema para
pasar a nuestros temas económicos hoy
con Daniela Blandón Daniela saludo
nuevamente para usted Hola Ángela y como
me lo voy a prometido pues ella se
conoció el dato de inflación de Estados
Unidos y usted nos cuenta Claro que sí
el índice de precios al consumidor en
este país tuvo un alza del 3% anual en
junio esto es un gran paso desde su
ritmo del 4% de mayo y mayor todavía el
paso si se tiene en cuenta que en junio
del año pasado había sido del 9,2% anual
en ese momento había marcado su nivel
más alto en cuatro décadas la sorpresa
vino por el lado de la inflación
subyacente que bajo más de lo esperado
al 4,8%, Esa inflación subyacente es la
que excluye los ítems muy volátiles como
son energía y alimentos y su
persistencia es la que tiene preocupado
al Banco Central vamos a ver en el
siguiente gráfico como esta inflación
subyacente Aunque ha cedido sigue siendo
todavía más del doble del objetivo del
2% de la Fed en general la inflación
está por encima de ese nivel por eso el
mercado no está abandonado La Apuesta de
que la reserva Federal va a subir un
poco más su tasa de interés en su
reunión del próximo 25 y 26 de junio hoy
ese tipo de referencia está entre el 5 y
el 5,25 por ciento y la inflación está
en 3% quiere decir que está más baja de
este referencia y vemos como había
habido un pico de un poco más del 9% en
junio del año pasado así que parece que
la tarea si la sana haciendo los
formuladores de política en Estados
Unidos y Esta es una oportunidad Daniela
para empezar a hablar desde los
indicadores de la jornada Pues los
principales índices de Wall Street
abrieron al alza después de que estos
datos mostraran que la inflación se
enfrió más de lo esperado Y eso lo que
hace es aumentar las esperanzas de los
inversionistas de que la reserva Federal
se está acercando al final de todo este
agresivo aumento de tasas de interés que
ha venido implementando en los últimos
meses Europa ya lo daba por montado
prácticamente sus principales índices
tuvieron buenas ganancias en la jornada
de hoy y Asia Cerro mixta con el
principal índice de Hong Kong subiendo
más del 1% ya había cerrado el mercado
Cuando surgió esta noticia de Estados
Unidos pero de todas maneras estaban
todos los ojos puestos sobre la
inflación hay otra reunión importante de
que se llevó a cabo el día de hoy y fue
la del gobierno francés Con los
sindicatos un mes después de las
protestas que fueron super extendidas
por Francia por la reforma pensional
Pues la primera ministra Elizabeth burn
recibió este miércoles y por alrededor
de dos horas a los representantes
sindicales eso para dar lo que llamó un
nuevo impulso al diálogo social tras
esta dolorosa crisis de las pensiones
después de sacar adelante la reforma que
eleva la edad de jubilación de 62 a 64
años quedaron muchos temas en el menú el
empleo de las personas mayores también
la prevención del desgaste profesional
sobre todo bajos pesados o los seguros
de desempleo entre otros
tenemos una agenda social ambiciosa y
muy densa para los próximos meses y creo
que es importante que los sindicatos y
las organizaciones empresariales pongan
de su parte para dar respuesta a las
inquietudes y preocupaciones de los
trabajadores y de los franceses en
general ha sido un encuentro positivo
que nos permite dejar constancia de esta
agenda de trabajo
Bueno una Elizabeth que ha estado en
muchos problemas precisamente por esta
reforma de las pensiones que se ha
dudado de su liderazgo pero ahí continúa
ahí sigue en su momento se llegó a decir
que esto la tenía muy en peligro y que
de pronto podía salir pero pues Ahí está
todavía por el momento con el respaldo
del presidente Daniela
vamos a hacer un cambio radical de temas
se acaba el tiempo de negociación entre
los actores y los representantes de los
estudios de Hollywood este tema
potencialmente podría ponerse bien
delicado Claro que sí va a ser más
noticia mañana todavía porque
saca trajes el sindicato más grande de
Hollywood representa a 160.000 actores y
está exigiendo principalmente dos cosas
Una mayor compensación en plena era del
streaming y salvaguardas en torno al uso
de Inteligencia artificial que dicen que
podría llegar a reemplazarlos porque
digo que va a ser más noticia todavía
mañana porque el plazo límite para
negociar y evitar una huelga vence a la
medianoche de este miércoles y las
partes aceptaron conversar hasta último
minuto inclusive con la ayuda de una
mediador Federal pero muchos creen que
la huelga es inminente grandes actrices
como Jennifer Lawrence y Meryl Streep
han dicho que están en listas para dejar
el trabajo lo cual es una gran presión
para los negociadores Claro que sí
además otra presión que tienen los
negociadores son ya los más de 11.000
afiliados al sindicato de guionistas que
también están en paro desde mayo 2 de
este año y el otro tema sobre el que
quisiera conversar Daniela y que me
genera pues mucha curiosidad sobre cómo
se a terminar desenlazando es el de la
discordia entre Taylor Swift y el
gigante de la venta de tiquetes que
continúa Claro que sí estos líos entre
Ticketmaster y la gira de Taylor Swift
comenzaron a finales del año pasado No
han terminado todavía el más reciente
capítulo tiene que ver con los fanáticos
que están esperando poder conseguir
entradas para su paso por Francia las
ventas en seis de sus próximos
espectáculos en París y en lío se
propusieron abruptamente con su
pospusieron con el Ticket Master citando
un problema con un proveedor externo
Aunque dijo que lo va a solucionar
cuanto antes este no es el primer choque
como lo decíamos en noviembre durante la
venta de boletos de la misma gira el
sitio de Ticketmaster colapsó durante la
preventa miles de personas Perdieron su
oportunidad de comprar boletos después
de esperar largas filas en línea Bueno
usted sabe que Taylor Swift tiene un
negocio completamente redondo ella no
solamente es la artista en lo que es
también la persona o la empresa que se
encarga de la logística de sus propios
conciertos así que bueno Por supuesto
que son ganancias por todos lados y que
en este momento le generan estas
fricciones con Ticketmaster pero no es
ella la única que tiene problemas con
este gigante de la venta de boletos esto
trasciende las fronteras y los
personajes claro y Comenzando por
Estados Unidos porque ya el congreso
acusó a Ticketmaster de abusar de su
posición dominante y yo biden está
impulsando una legislación para poner en
cintura lo que él ha llamado las tarifas
basura que se refieren a la poca
Claridad en los precios y en cobros
exagerados por servicios adicionales
este gigante de entretenimiento procesa
unos 500 millones de boletos al año en
más de 30 países concentra el mercado en
Estados Unidos y está en la mira de
otras naciones agencias defensoras de
derechos de los consumidores en México
en Argentina en chile y hasta en España
la han acusado de falta de transparencia
Bueno vamos a ir con otro tema que
también pienso que es importante sobre
todo con un tema de servicio para
nuestros usuarios Daniela Banco América
pagará un millonario un monto y esto por
engañar a sus clientes pues Banco
América es el segundo banco más grande
de Estados Unidos acaba de acordar un
pago de 250 millones de dólares en
multas y en compensaciones para resolver
reclamos según los cuales habrían
ocurrido en varias violaciones a las
leyes según la oficina de protección
financiera al consumidor hacía por
ejemplo dobles cobros o retuvo
beneficios prometidos en tarjetas de
crédito y abrió cuentas sin la
autorización de los clientes
cosechando cientos de millones de
dólares por ejemplo era difícil de
entender como un usuario se le aplicaba
una tarifa de 35 dólares por una
transacción declinada Ahora hay
respuesta de parte y parte el regulador
dice que estas prácticas son ilegales
que socavan la confianza del cliente y
que va a tratar de que esto no ocurra en
el sistema bancario por su parte el
banco América dice que redujo
voluntariamente estas tarifas y que
eliminó todos estos cargos por fondos
insuficientes y de esta manera
ha generado una reducción del 90% en
esas tarifas en el último año sin
embargo nos falta todavía muchísimo a
los usuarios para podernos defender más
o poder tener más conocimiento sobre
nuestros derechos en términos
financieros lo importante Ángela siempre
es denunciar estos actos Porque si los
consumidores financieros no lo hacen
pues difícilmente las autoridades van a
llegar hasta ellos pues bien Daniela
creo que con este tema ya cumplimos
nuestra cuota para economía por esta
mañana pero seguro que mañana tendremos
mucho más de que hablar así que muchas
gracias a ustedes bueno acá nos vemos
mañana